hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Arianna
ariana's back on the channel saw her
perform at The Comedy Store in LA
had forgot was called uh the comedy
Smith yeah she did stand-up comedy
she was [ __ ] hilarious so I was like
she's got to come back on the channel be
funny all right I'm gonna try
so from Screen Rant we're gonna check
out 10 movie bloopers that made it to
the final cut this should be exciting we
know a thing or two about bloopers
we're supposed to be serious forward we
can't do it
even the most intensive dramatic movies
can't keep actors from goofing around
which means plenty of blooper reels and
blown takes for fans to enjoy Jim the
credits or as a bonus on home videos but
sometimes a spur-of-the-moment decision
mistake or even an injury can be too
good to cut make sure you comment below
as you watch because we want to know
what you guys think of our videos here
are screen rants 10 movie bloopers that
made to the final cut Django Unchained
Quentin Tarantino's Western was one of
only a few movies to put Leonardo
DiCaprio in a supporting role but the
actor found a surprising way to prove
he's always a super stuff during the
movie's climactic dinner scene Calvin
Candy's anger explodes resulting in
broken bone smashed glass and blood the
injury was completely unplanned other
actors were clearly stunned as the
director and actor kept on rolling you
can even watch as DiCaprio picks the
glass from his hand once his speeches
over
hopefully the blood smeared on his
co-star wasn't the real thing Mission
Impossible was enough when building the
final fight in Mission Impossible honey
Tom Cruise and his stuntman trained to
make the routes as realistic as possible
and that included letting a knife swing
just millimeters from his eyes but when
his fellow Stedman told crews not to
pull back on his final kick he did it
blasting his foot squarely on his
partner's job director John who used the
entire shot including the stars clearly
shocked reaction to his mistake
oh no dealer's world famous male model
is known more for his looks than a smart
but one joke concerning Derek's low IQ
rose above the rest
when David Duke company's character
explains why male models make the
perfect brainwashed assassins Eric
doesn't quite keep up that moment wasn't
planned still they're simply forgot his
next line and instead of ruining the
take repeated the question but why male
model serious I just I just told you
that a moment
right do company didn't miss a beat
giving as deadpan a response as he could
delivering one of the more memorable
jokes in the movie knocked-up stars Seth
Rogen Jason Segel Jonah Hill and Jay
Baruchel opened the movie with a montage
of wasting time capping the scene off
with a ride on a spinning roller coaster
a ride not all of them enjoy bearish
shells fear of roller coasters was so
strong he agreed to appear naked in the
movie just to avoid the rot but the
director and cast pushed him to do it
meaning Seagal had to appear in the
flesh instead and bare shells genuine
terror made it into the final movie
Raiders of the Lost Ark when Indiana
Jones attempts to ambush a group of
Nazis with his leading lady held
prisoner the movies villain Belloc takes
part in a surprise cameo a fly suddenly
appearing on an actor's face can usually
ruin a take but the bug disappearing
implies something much worse according
to actor Paul Freeman the effects team
thought it would be funnier to erase the
flies escape turning what could have
been a blown take into an infamous
moment that's impossible to miss Lauren
ursa Midnight Cowboy this one is quite
possibly the most famous blooper in
movie history Brad so Rizzo's
catchphrase and Midnight Cowboy was
completely unplanned as the crew
secretly filmed actors Dustin Hoffman
and Jon Voight on a New York Street a
taxi nearly hit the pair of them
crossing the street but as Jon Voight
watched on in surprise Hoffman turned
the blown take it's not just the most
well known scene in the movie but a line
that would become even more well known
in iconic and he could have ever guessed
walking here walking half the Lord of
The Rocketeer first arrives to visit
Bilbo in Bag End he shows how hard it
can be to move through a miniature home
after Ian McKellen's fumbling with the
chandelier was planned but his sudden
slam into a ceiling beam wasn't a
surprise shout and laugh were too good
to leave out and Peter Jackson left and
the finished film later
Ridley Scott's sci-fi detective story
made actress Daryl Hannah an
up-and-coming star overnight but her
dedication to the role went beyond act
and her characters introduced she panics
running off and smashing the window of
the park been the stunner wasn't planned
meaning Hannah's simply scribed into the
band with enough force to shatter the
very real glass and her elbow along with
it she remained in character making sure
the mistake wound up in the original
film ouch
wound up in surgery herself Green Man
stars Tom Cruise and Dustin Hoffman were
at the top of their game in this tale of
dysfunctional brothers but some
unintended flatulence was to thank for
one of its most famous moments when the
Paras squeezed into a phone booth
Hoffman's character takes things from
bad to worse passing some gas in the
cramped space oh Clark that's Charlie
bad our Hoffman wasn't making it up
except they're giving us co-star
heads-up cruise tickets you two stay in
character and the rest is history
how can you scare them I owe my back to
them to run away stars of the Back to
the Future series but the futuristic
gadgets also led to one of the trilogy's
most disastrous stunts when VIPs gang
tries to take out Marty in 2015 they
wind up smashing through a courthouse
window risky stunt called for all three
actors to fly through the glass before
dropping safely below but an error since
not woman Cheryl wheeler Dickson's
climbing into a pillar instead with the
timing thrown off she was dropped 30
feet onto the stone below she survived
the fall but sustained serious injuries
and the more shocking the stunt was only
performed once meaning her fault can
actually be seen in the finished film
thankfully cutting away a split-second
before him so what do you think of our
list
did we miss any of your favorite
bloopers or happy accidents that ended
up in movies let us know in a comment
section and don't forget to subscribe to
our channel for more videos like this
one
that's cool man I like seeing these
movies where these improvised moments or
mistakes are actually like the best
moments of the film that authenticity
right it's a real Syrah so raw you know
it's like the directors like which then
the moment was just an accident but it
just it added such realism to the story
Leo with the glass hands Leo what that
was impressive could you commit to
something like that you're an actress
Arianna you do improv if you broke I do
improv you just go with it you know it
improv when you get glass in your hand
there's no glass just want to clarify
but in acting yeah I feel like that's
the most raw I have actually shattered
glass on stage really during a play I
like slammed down a glass and shattered
everywhere and the next thing they were
barefoot so did you go with it already
yeah no I made it it was the opening the
first thing that happened before we
started the scene these things work
great for actors because they need to
provide whatever real because the best
thing with actors is like oh that moment
they had right so to provide those
moments I remember watching Mission
Impossible - when Tom Cruise does that
kick to the guy's jaw I was like oh that
looks real and then now you know finding
out it's real that's sharpen the knife I
oh yeah
Tom Cruise man do whatever you can to
distract people from the fact that
you're a Scientologist huh
but know that jaw kick I'm surprised I
didn't kill the guy I know I heard that
if you punch a guy right here like
directly force yeah just a punch the jaw
bones right here will go and hit they're
like brain yeah something like that hit
there die and they could die same thing
with a palm to the nose yeah you're
supposed to go like yeah and then it
could kill them then this could knock
them sorry boxing so I understand you
box now yes you can punch yeah nah yeah
and I was also a yellow belt which is
one up from white weight was a Jewish
karate
what is Jewish crime this is a lime lime
hey money money
yes I know hi I'm La Hoya honey there is
one thing is because I'm watching these
and I'm like I could roll with the
punches on that the one I couldn't roll
with was the guy with the fly going in
his mouth that I would have been like I
got a cup of camera or something because
that's just what are they saying that
they edited out the fly leaving so it
looks like it went in smell oh I thought
they were saying win in its mouth and
then they have it out instead of edited
I'm pretty sure I'm right let's hope so
otherwise you're gonna disappoint all
the Jewish fanbase I cannot be the only
Jewish girl or guy you've ever had on
here you are the only Jewish person I've
ever had on this channel you see Ariana
weren't Hollywood we're watching
Hollywood videos I realized you're
people run this industry I need to get
in good with you so that way this is
your way of getting in good with me yeah
man Jews are awesome they did nothing in
my man Jesus okay let's just do this my
favorite one would have to be so hard
the fart you know because I remember
watching that scene guy that's some good
acting right there they managed to make
a physical fart joke comedy moment
actually working it's cool this is real
it's just real it's just real sometimes
I fart to make people uncomfortable too
just to get a reaction out of them I did
have a burping whoa okay react like a
weak one I was not bad I've asked it
reflex especially for a Jew really good
Jews anyway guys if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects are you out of boss or you could
follow her on social networks especially
her youtube channel which we were
talking about she's she has some things
in the pipeline that she wants it yeah I
gotta edit some ish yeah some ish like
your day your hair black everyone what's
the pony's what everyone like the blonde
no no one like the blonde all the
comments were like she looks like that
guy what's a guy who is it I don't know
no my hair is naturally dark is it I
look you know this I don't remember my
hair has only ever been dark except for
six months of my life
I went on your channel I choose to block
out mostly memories I'd ever thought
never the pilot we did nine to twenty
five whatever it's better with dark hair
I don't wanna hear about it okay
okay and overalls too that's good heyyou
falls on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
and periscope where if we get enough
followers we can do product placement
more product placement meaning more
chi-ching for the real rejects more
money for me no real benefit for you
people like you should use that money
invest it back into the channel no I'll
make money one day one day I mean you're
Jewish so it's like your man awesome
yeah it's a way to do it whether you
just be cheaper you know whatever the
reputation I have developed myself in
these last three videos with you it's
exquisite yeah I is more to me there's a
lot more in all honesty I'm gonna take a
moment to be sincere Arianna is actually
very talented
seriously I saw her perform on stage
doing stand-up it takes a lot of guts to
go up on a stand-up stage especially at
the Comedy Store
she was [ __ ] hilarious I've known her
to be someone who's kind of like a
little bit in between of what she wants
but lately I'm noticing that she saw him
yeah you're honing in on stuff you're
taking the work you're putting in the
work on yourself you're putting in the
work on your career I'm seeing that you
have a really ambitious side and I know
I make a lot of jokes but truth is like
I'm very I do respect you a lot and I'm
very and that's the only reason I bring
you on the channel so yeah that was
great I feel great now